assalamualaikum greetings of peace to
everybody from the Dean show i'm eddie
host of the Dean shown to everybody all
over the globe thank you for supporting
the Dean show thank you for sharing our
programs thank you for watching the
program and hopefully you've been able
to tremendously benefit and God willing
you can help to help us take the Dean
show to the next level now we need to
get these programs out we'd like to
market it we'd like to continue the
daily operations we like to get more
guests there are so many so many things
we'd like to do but everything costs we
need to be out there educating the
people and one of the means is through
the Dawa the Dow are inviting people to
the purpose of life educating them
clearing the many misconceptions and how
are we going to do it if we're just
chasing the dunya and we're not taking
on the responsibilities so the crater
tells us what the purpose of life is
well Michael up to lagina well in
soluble dune I've not created mankind
except to worship me one of the greatest
acts of worship along with the five
pillars along with being of noble
character along with being the best in
society is following the way the sunnah
of the last and final messenger sent to
mankind and all the messengers they all
did our they call people to the way of
life that was sent by the Creator Islam
submission to the creator of the
creation and that education is so
important so we need to educate the
people we need to invite them and all of
this costs all this cost so help
contribute to running and spreading this
message and you'll get the reward
mandela allah hide in falmouth Latifah
the one who invites someone to good will
have the reward equivalent to the one
who does it without diminishing years so
if you're contributing to something good
and now somebody hears the message
because you helped support this program
and now they end up accepting Islam they
end up spraying and their character gets
better and they live the purpose of life
and you contributed to it you get the
reward man come on now so ladies and
gents brothers and sisters contribute to
the cause contribute towards the Dawa
the education of humanity and you
inshallah we'll have a ticket by the
permission of Allah when you're working
for the Dean support
Nadine on the day of judgment all that
all those good deeds will be waiting for
you inshallah we can get to Jenna by
doing what our crate has told us to do
and support in a dollar so support the
Dawa support the Dean show contribute
and help us spread this message this
message of peace peace acquired by
submission to the will of God Islam
we'll see you next time tune in every
week to the Dean show follow us on the
Twitter on the facebook subscribe to our
YouTube channels and wherever you're
watching us continue to watch a same
time same Channel peace be unto you
assalamu alaikum